I still think that great story that you
did on The Tonight Show when Nicole
Kidman was a guest she she wanted [ __ ]
you [ __ ] your brains out she comes over
to your apartment and Nicole Kidman's
hot and famous and you know before you
were married it was the worst that was
like a Larry
you still don't understand how even
paying her how did you not pick up on
this because I was on Sara alive and I
was just I was just single and just
walking around and just just being
whatever I just been The Bachelor life
had sneakers and video game but any girl
who came to my apartment I just assumed
she wants a thug it was afternoon it was
it wasn't like him but anything and then
and then like and then you sat there and
played video games well he was sat there
and like was trying to seduce you with
that my friend Rick calls me goes dude
Nicole kid I'm with Nicole Kidman she
wants to come to your partners with and
meet with you that be wish'd Oh
so I go wow cool it end up going to Will
Ferrell but I'm like cool i could play
they were thinking of you being a being
daran daran yeah I could see that it'd
be fun yeah why not oh great I go
fantastic goes so I go but my place is a
mess I don't know what's going on the
cold came in you can't bring let's meet
somewhere else you go we're just totally
pressure wants to go to the apartment
ago all right okay go just get some
cheese and crackers and we'll be good
and cracker so am I gonna get that what
cheesy just get brie and crackers and go
that's okay
so I didn't know what brie is right so I
go into the deli by my house I go to
make brie is what and I was like I don't
even know it if I grabbed brie which I
don't know what it is and I grab I
bought saltines and all tea it's so
embarrassing it I seriously I put it on
a plate and I opened the plastic wrap of
the saltines and I kind of sand it out a
little bit today looks fancy yeah oh you
made a presentation exactly thank you
man bachelor peg and I don't have a
cheese knife so I have a butter knife
yeah and the thing of Brie which I go do
I take this thing off the plastic the
Rhine yeah I didn't know it's called
Iraq at the time yeah I go knows that I
don't know what I do with this then
scoop out the middle this is the whole
thing tonight see I would have opened a
can of nuts then you have no no qualms
peanut allergy yeah oh [ __ ] yeah maybe
alright get win anymore so she walks in
she walks in I go and I'm like nervous
did you think she was hot gorgeous
gorgeous right gorgeous I mean it's a
no-brainer by far the most
beautiful person ever walked in my part
but you thought it was like oh she's
discussing the movie I'm trying to be
professional right yeah I'm a I want to
be someone you want to work in a movie
with Brian Grimaud yeah not some guy
who's just going to jump on top of me
yeah right
but I couldn't even consider that I
would have a chance if I like a result
given so she sits down and she was know
well what are all these wires what some
of that well no these boils yeah okay
Australian but and I go up this that's a
Nintendo game I've Nintendo games here's
what what Kay what Keynes you're playing
I was like uh now she's British
necessary close enough Ricky Gervais
throw it out I'm about to have an affair
with David Bowie so I go area card item
as I teach her I guess wants here to
play princess the gasps I don't even
know what I was doing right I taught her
how to play the video game Oh Mary ocher
oh so nice and you can get the part I
didn't get the part and but I wonder
what will Ferrell this do probably bang
the [ __ ]